[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
haben sie während der pandemie
umarmungen vermisst oder hoffen sie ganz
im gegenteil dass diese gießerei und
druckerei bei der begrüßung gar nicht
mehr zu unseren gewohnheiten zurück
findet der mensch scheint ein wesen der
berührung zu sein nicht nur körperlich
sondern auch seelisch und geistig doch
was berührt uns und was wollen wir
berühren wirst du nähe suchen wir in
wahrheit die nähe des unberührbaren
gottes oder einfach das nichts und was
geschieht wenn die berührung fehlt oder
wir zur berührung genötigt werden
darüber spreche ich heute mit anne koch
professorin für religionswissenschaft an
der universität freiburg im breisgau und
willem schmid philosoph und autor schön
dass sie da sind
beginnen wir mit dem unmöglichen er
schmidt wie würden sie einem wesen das
die berührung nicht kennt das heißt über
alle andere sinne verfügt aber nicht
über den tastsinn die erfahrung der
berührung erläutert
ich würde höflich fragen darf ich mal
und würde dann mal
erst mal nur über die schulter
streicheln vorausgesetzt dieses wesen
hat eine schulter nehmen wir an ja
und dann würde das wesen möglicherweise
sagen oh das tut gut nach weiterer
dann würde ich mich ein bisschen weiter
vorwagen schau mal würde ich sagen das
ist berührung das heißt wenn es nicht
versuchen sprachlich diese erfahrung zu
vermitteln sondern durch die aktion
selbst
also wenn die berührung erst sprachlich
vermittelt werden muss
das kommt ja auch zwischen paaren so
höre ich vor dass die sprachlich
vermittelt wird nachts mal praktisch
würde ich sagen und dann könnte er
hinterher ja darüber reflektieren und
und was ist mit einem wesen das
überhaupt nicht vorüber ist also in
diesem tasten nicht kennt dann müssen
sie in wien zu vermitteln
es wäre ja ein wesen insofern wäre es
mit sicherheit durch darum von energie
denn anders können wesen nicht gewesen
sein also würde ich ein energiepaket
rüber schicken und dann mal gucken wie
das wesen aufleuchtet das würde dann
heißen aber es ist von meinem
energiepaket berührt worden
lassen sie uns gerade am anfang in eine
ganz besondere welt für eine weile
eintauchen wo berührung beinahe das
einzige kommunikationsmittel ist in die
welt der menschen die taub blind sind
die
[Musik]
unsere taubblinden menschen wissen ja
eigentlich gar nicht dass sie sterben
müssen und wir hatten vor kurzem den
vorfall dass ein elternteil verstorben
ist und der roland hat sein vater total
lieb gehabt
und wir mussten dann überlegen wie
machen wir das zu und sind dann mit ihm
einen tag vorher vor der beerdigung zu
ihm gefahren dass er sich verabschieden
kann und wird dann unten angekommen sind
haben wir den rahmen gemeinsam betreten
und ich habe ihnen dann die möglichkeit
gegeben dass er erst einmal den sack in
aller ruhe abtasten darf und dann habe
ich ihm gezeigt das gesicht ist von
seinem vater und er konnte das dann auch
vorsichtig abtasten und ich habe mich
dann ein wenig zurückgenommen und ich
habe ihnen dann beobachtet und er hat
den total liebevoll das gesicht geführt
und das war ja eine ganze weile gemacht
und irgendwann bin ich dann zu ihm
gegangen und wir haben dann auch wieder
den raum verlassen
und seitdem hat er nie wieder auf seinen
vater gewartet
liebe frau koch wie sind oder hören über
menschen die ja nahezu auf diese
berührung reduziert sind welche frage
drin sich bei ihnen auf wenn sie an
diese menschen denken
ja die frage ist wie weit das begreifen
dann über den tastsinn über das
haptische über das taktile dann bei
diesen menschen gehen kann also im film
sah man ja sehr schön wie sogar
leblosigkeit solche abstrakten begriffe
dass jemand verschwindet mit dem man
eine enge bindung hat menschliches wesen
da nicht mehr zu der welt gehören kann
solche abstrahieren sind dann auch aus
dem ertasten wärme temperaturempfinden
möglich ja und die merken auch dass wir
in gewisser weise mehrere ebenen der
berührung bereits hier stand antreffen
zum einen es wird über die berührung
gesprochen diese intensive form der
berührung fast schon über intensiv und
auf der anderen seite berührt uns diese
erfahrung wenn wir von ihr hören ich
habe auch anfangs erwähnt es gibt ja
nicht nur die berührung sondern die
berührung schreiben differenziert zu
sein es gibt körperliche seelische und
geistige mögen sie uns diese kurz
einordnen der schmitz am besten mit
einem jeweiligen beispiel die sind ja
nicht absolut voneinander getrennt
wenn ich einen anderen menschen berühre
und das ist mehr als nur eine
oberflächliche berührung dann werden
auch gefühle dabei wach und
möglicherweise schießen den menschen und
mir selber auch gedanken in den kopf
sehen kann man die körperliche berührung
die seelische berührung die
möglicherweise noch wichtiger ist die
können wir nicht sehen aber die hat ganz
sicher mit den energien zu tun die uns
durchs leben tragen die uns mit dem ende
des lebens verlassen
die schwerlich zu bestreiten sind die
teilweise auch zu benennen sind also
wenn ich über eine hand streiche dann
fahre ich wärmeenergie und wir wissen
aufgrund von ekg und eeg herz und hirn
abend mit elektrizität zu tun also in
uns sind energien
und diese energien vermutlich noch
einige mehr die wir nicht so gut
benennen können und vielleicht auch noch
nicht kennen diese energien in würde mir
vorstellen in energie paketen und
schicken wir über wenn wir gefühle für
einen menschen haben oder gefühle von
einem menschen in empfang nehmen wir
wissen in beziehung oft relativ gut nie
wissen ist ein zu hoher begriff wir
spüren in beziehung relativ gut wie die
stimmung ist was ist denn die stimmung
das hat eben mit dieser art der energie
zu tun die unsichtbar ist die zwischen
uns aber sehr wohl wirksam ist und ich
nehme an dass auch gedanken
energiepakete sind die zwischen menschen
ausgetauscht werden können und da ist es
äußerst interessant dass wir auch heute
noch nach 2400 jahren von gedanken
platons beispielsweise oder ist alles
total es erfasst sein können dass also
diese energiepakete die gedanken sind
durch die zeit reisen können und sogar
noch ein bisschen länger als 1400 jahre
gibt es reine eine ebene der berührung
die noch zu ergänzen wäre broker
neben diesen drei hier differenziert
gehört musste gerade daran denken wie
wichtig es ist dass die emotionale
berührung die geistige die künstlerische
ästhetische berührung dass die so stark
abhängig sind von körperlichen grund
vollzügen also den erfahrungen berührt
zu werden sich an irgendetwas zu stoßen
wenn man sich im raum orientiert und
viele symbolisieren die dann im
emotionalen nähe ferne
oberschicht unterschicht stattfinden
dass es immer an solche körperlichen
grund wahrnehmungen der welt zurück
gebunden bleibt und wie sieht es aus
geführt haben dass auch in emotionalen
beziehungen vieles nicht exakt in worte
zu bringen ist nicht ganz und gar
expliziert werden kann in regel
zusammenhang sondern immer auch so viel
politisches verständnis behält ein
situatives
verständnisses szene in der man sich
bewegt und da bewegt man sich eben drin
das hat man als mensch gelernt zu
verarbeiten ja in der tat ich glaube das
interessante ist ja transzendente
berührung die noch dazu kommt zur
körperlichen seelischen geistigen
und die nun am allerwenigsten zu fassen
ist
und religionen scheinen sich dann darauf
zu
verlegt zu haben schon relativ früh aber
doch berührungen einzuführen um die
transzendente berührung erfahrbar zu
machen also zum beispiel durch
aufgelegte hand
die einzige möglichkeit wahrscheinlich
um transzendente berührungen den
horizont zu bringen der uns zugänglich
ist und das ist nun mal der fassbare
horizont
transzendente berührung kann ich mir
vorstellen ist eine berührung
der energie die nicht nur uns im leben
durchzieht und nicht nur unseren
planeten durchzieht sondern den ganzen
kosmos durchzieht
schwerlich zu bestreiten das ist so und
da kommt noch dunkle energie dazu und
wie wir nicht genau kennen da wird also
in zukunft noch sehr viel zu erforschen
seien aber eine transzendenz im wortsinn
verstanden transzendieren überschreiten
das überschreitet uns unendlich und
dieses unendlich überschreitende zu
spüren in gefühlen gedanken und
vermittelt doch eine körperliche
berührung das ist vermutlich dann
tanzten den titel darf ich ihnen
widersprechen weil mir gerade die die
setzung von transzendenz das was
überschreitet wer gerade den gedanken
vermittelt es eben alles zu sein aber
nicht berührt das ist ja gerade ein
begriff der distanz und gerade nicht ein
begriff der nähe die sonst jeder form
der berührung auch suggeriert wie können
wir also überhaupt von einer
transzendente wo der spirituelle wäre
ein geistiger oder metaphysische oder
diese begriffe überhaupt im sinne der
berührung sprechen wie ist die
religionen aber augenscheinlich tun
ja also meint zugang als
religionswissenschaftlerin wäre jetzt da
zu sagen religionen sind teil von kultur
und als kulturwesen symbolisieren wir
viel und brauchen auch materialisierung
'nen für abwesende
gegenstände bilder
haare irgendwer etwas das für andere
personen steht oder auch für etwas dem
wir bedeutung zuschreiben aber was die
sichtbar ist oder sichtbar wird diese
imaginationskraft auch die ist gebunden
an diese verkörperte kognition und hat
von daher ganz viele wichtige kategorien
bekommen
aber wie sehr das dann wirklichkeit ist
die alles durchzieht das wären ja dann
sehr metaphysische aussagen das würde
ich jetzt eher von
der richtung beschreiben dass da
verschiedene gruppierungen bestimmte
bedeutungs zuschreibungen machen sich
auf zeichen einigen die dann für sie
etwa eine bestimmte gottheit
repräsentieren oder eine bestimmte kraft
im universum oder schädliche kräfte die
man dann abwehren möchte indem man
gegenstände am körper trägt wenn man
anfassen kann wo man sich seiner selbst
versichert die man der kraft vielleicht
sogar entgegenhalten kann also da gibt
es ja die religionen benutzen ja sehr
sehr stark das berühren wo was
abzuwehren sich zu vergewissern
bleiben wir einfach erst einmal bei dem
christentum jesus heute eigentlich kaum
berührungen
nahm kinder in seinen armen bush die
füße seinen jüngern er berührte menschen
blinde
um ihn sozusagen heilig erfahren zu
lassen was den stellenwert hat die
prüfung explizit wie das christentum
also in diesen literarischen zeugnissen
die wir haben über diese gestalt ist in
der tat sehr oft von berührung die rede
nachdem religionen teil von kultur ist
ist es wichtig da auch den kontext sich
anzuschauen wie hat man im vorderen
orient sich berührt wie in welcher
schicht gab es welche formen der
berührung wiener hat man einander
geschlafen wie hat man zu tisch gesessen
das macht ganz viel für eine berührung
skulptur aus welchen ehe da ist von
dieser literarischen gestalt da wird
sehr deutlich beschrieben wie sie sich
von personen berühren lässt
obwohl das bestimmte codes werden darf
berühren wer darf ihn berühren gebrochen
hat und das hat dann alles natürlich
eine aussage dass diese gestalt
bestimmte exklusion mechanismen
überwunden hat und mehr menschen hinein
nehmen möchte in den geltungsbereich
ihrer botschaft also das feld sehr stark
auf und dann ist diese gestalten heiler
personen auch und in bezug auf das
heilen das zieht sich wirklich durch in
vielen kulturen da ist es berühren
extrem wichtig
dieses der tod bei toten erwägungen
körper auf körper nase auf nase bei
einheits erlebnissen bei die der einsatz
von bestimmten substanzen
körpersubstanzen speichel zum beispiel
leben heilmittel die man an bestimmte
körperzonen aufträgt
religionen sind ja nicht vom himmel
gefallen wenn ich die bewegung glauben
dass es viele so
soll heißen die beruhen auf menschlichen
erfahrungen und es ist eine menschliche
erfahrungen die jeder von uns auch
machen kann dass wir uns in gewisser
weise auch heilen können durch
handauflegen also geht auch mit einem
selbst ja ich habe das mal gemacht als
ich zahnschmerzen hatte und kein sanders
die hand aufzulegen
milderte den schmerz das ist keine
endgültige heilmethode irgendwann muss
schon auch der zahnarzt dazu kommen aber
das ist erst mal oder eltern kennen das
phänomen
dass kinder früher war das jedenfalls so
dass kinder mal hinfallen durften und
sich das knie aufschlagen durften heute
werden die im flug schon aufgefangen
aber als das noch der fall war
nostalgische erinnerung kommen die
kinder gelaufen fliegen in den armen
ihrer eltern
und es vergeht vielleicht ein zwei
minuten und dann rennt davon das blut
läuft noch runter vom knie aber sie sind
subjektiv geheilt und dazwischen liegt
nur die umarmung durch die eltern es hat
sehr lange gedauert bis
wissenschaft dahinter gekommen ist was
da eigentlich geschieht dieses wissen
ist nicht sehr viel älter als 30 jahre
bis dahin war es einfach nur
erfahrungswissen aber seither ist klar
bei berührung werden endorphine frei und
endorphine sind nun mal etwas hinten
betäubungsmittel das eingesetzt werden
kann um schmerzen zu betäuben eine der
wirkungen also sehr früh auch als
menschen noch nicht wussten was
endorphin ist fit und
diverse hormone die bei berührung frei
werden sehr früh schon vor tausenden von
jahren wurden die phänomene beobachtet
und die wurden eingebaut in einen
religiösen kontext ich verstehe das
heißt im grunde genommen
würden sie sagen dass religionen sich
diese diese erfahrung bedienen user
weiter was ein zutiefst menschlicher
erfahrung ist der berührung um dann ihre
eigene botschaft da hineinzubringen
sie können das aufgreifen verstärken was
gesellschaftlich gilt oder sogar
subversiv sein oder in opposition gehen
zu bestimmten berührungs weisen also
weil berührung er diesen bedeutungs
überschuss hat der soziale nähe und
bindung gibt es da ganz viele
gestaltungsmöglichkeiten
einige beispiele aus anderen religiösen
formen geben religiösen mit kulturen wie
sie sagen jenseits des christentums
berührung
spezifisch sichtbar wird ja also wenn
wir in die gegenwart schauen da hat sich
ja mit der zweiten moderne das religiöse
fällt noch mal sehr stark gewandelt es
sind sehr viele formen dazu gekommen die
sich im bereich der körperlichkeit
bewegen etwa die rezeption von
kampfsportarten von körper praktiken wie
yoga ayurveda solche heil formen und in
dem bereich sieht man dass vieles in der
sprache geht die gar nicht mehr religiös
ist also so was gar nicht abruft und
trotzdem aber zum beispiel auch im
tanzbereich kontakt improvisation mit
der berührung mit dem zugehen auf andere
personen ganz stark arbeitet viele
körpertherapie ausbildungen die
letztlich dann aber wieder aus
bestimmten religiösen hintergründen
kamen sich dessen oft gar nicht mehr
bewusst sind und sich jetzt für ein
breiteres publikum für eine
bevölkerungsschicht die der religion
entfremdet ist in dieser traditionellen
form da einen zugang gibt also gerade in
bezug auf den individualismus da eine
möglichkeit gibt mit sich ins reine zu
kommen achtsam zu sein das wären zum
beispiel solche
formen dass man trainiert die innen
wahrnehmung also ganze atem
meditations- workshops sind sehr viele
möglichkeiten die da angeboten werden na
ja sie haben den den sozialen aspekten
kulturellen aspekt der berührung auch
kurz erwähnt was glaube ich ganz in
ihrem sinne wäre es zu sagen im grunde
genommen wenn berührungen so zentral
sind in allen religionsformen dann müsse
die berührung selbst als phänomen etwas
haben was die anderen tasten sehr wohl
nicht mitbringen nämlich etwas was uns
and individualisiert sie haben einmal
gesprochen von
ausbrechen aus dem gefängnis das ist
etwas was eigentlich nicht geschieht
wenn wir eine person nur sehen nein ich
nehme sie ist uns dann war dann bin ich
derjenige der sie wahrnehmen wenn sie
bemerken sondern wenn wir uns berühren
dann geschieht zwischen uns etwas was
religiöses inwiefern und zu
überschreiten die überschreitung
erfahrung ist immer die religiöse
erfahrung und religionen sind aus meiner
sicht diejenigen die das wesentliche
beharren die den bezug zum wesentlichen
bewahren und das wesentliche ist bin ich
überzeugt davon energie in allen ihren
vielen verschiedenen formen die
unsterblich sind die ineinander
umgewandelt werden können und die in
bestimmten
bei bestimmten erfahrungen stärker frei
werden als bei anderen
was man diese erfahrung werde jetzt von
ihnen dass sie kurz unterbrochen habe
sie werden gleich in gedanken aufnehmen
energie für sie ein so zentraler begriff
der erklärung ist mögen sie uns noch
einmal erklären was sie darunter genau
verstehen energisches möglichkeit erst
mal ruhen so wirklich gemein sie sich
erfüllt den raum als ruhende möglichkeit
erfüllt sie den raum irgendwann
vielleicht durch unsere magnetischen
kräfte wird sie von uns angezogen und
wird zu einer gerichteten möglichkeit
und damit können wir sprechen damit
können wir blicken dass es das typische
was tote
sie können nicht blicken sie können
nicht sprechen weil die energie aus
ihnen entwichen ist und berührung ist
nun mal eine möglichkeit wunderbar
energie zu erfahren schon in der
berührung mit sich selbst aber noch sehr
viel mehr in der berührung mit anderen
wesen und speziell mit anderen menschen
können wir über berührungen energien
austauschen und das geschieht so rasch
dieser energieaustausch dass wir beide
wenn es zwei sind über weit mehr energie
verfügen als eine für sich allein das
ist eine transzendente und ich möchte
sogar sagen religiös erfahrung denn wenn
sie mal zum beispiel liebende fragen
nach dieser erfahrung beschreibt das
doch mal dann werden die sagen das ist
göttlich
höchstes attribut das ist gänzlich ja es
ist eine göttliche erfahrung hat nämlich
eine erfahrung von energie und die kann
man nun einkleiden in geschichten eben
die geschichten die von jesus
überliefert sind und diese geschichten
kann man weitererzählen menschen lieben
geschichten das ist vollkommen in
ordnung aber das wesentliche dieser
geschichte ist dass es um energien geht
ja so still würden sie dem zustimmen mit
dieser begrifflichkeit ich hoffe doch
nicht ja wahrscheinlich ist jetzt diese
begrifflichkeit finde ich sehr
interessant sie trägt viel aussieht
kommt sehr häufig vor im religiösen
fällt der gegenwart das ganze universum
ist ein bewusstsein ist eine universelle
energie die durch zieht alles und unsere
grob stofflichen körper die stehen so im
mittelpunkt und weiten sich aber aus
auch in das feinstoffliche auch die haut
grenze ist nicht unbedingt die grenze
des körpers sondern der körper hat noch
so und so viele körperhöhlen also das
sind so sehr gängige vorstellungen aus
der theosophie aus fernöstlichen medizin
systemen religions- systemen und die
finden wir ganz häufig auch als symbole
wackeren energiearbeit in der heilungs
arbeit und das ist sehr prägend also für
viele die sich auf die weise auch so was
wie verletzungen oder kontakt mit
anderen vorstellen also da muss ich
nicht die haut berühren da kann auch ein
böses wort das in meinem körper
nahbereich eindringt ist bereits eine
verschmutzung meines energie feldes um
sollte dann gereinigt werden also
insofern trägt das einiges aus und geht
einher mit dieser idee das berühren das
für das rennen ganz wichtig ist die
grenzziehungen ist das meine haut dieses
riesige organen oder wo genau ist
eigentlich die grenze und wann wird die
überschritten wann wird sie verletzt wie
wird sie ausgehandelt
vereinzelt mich die berührung wenn ich
es danach vermisse oder verbindet sie
mich gerade mit anderen also ich glaube
dass mitteln ausgetragen richtig sagen
die die ergänzungen und
ausdifferenzierung das sind was sie
unter seine dem begriff der energie
erklären würden sie sagen dass es
vielleicht gar nicht primär auch um die
berührung selbst geht sondern um eine
tiefe einstellung dass unsere
leiblichkeit wir sind eben wesen die
leidlich verfasst sind und dadurch haben
wir auch eine ganz andere energetische
form im leben die heißt vorüber zu sein
für die philosophen spielte seit der
frühen neuzeit eine große rolle das
berühmte cogito ergo sum ich denke also
bin ich ich habe das auch lange geglaubt
bis mir deutlicher wurde welche rolle
die berührung spielt schon mal rein die
körperliche berührung so dass sich wenn
ich mir das vor augen führe
besser sagen lese tango tango ergo sum
tango ich berühre der tanzbilder tangos
der geht nicht auf eine berührung
deswegen heißt ja so tango ich berühre
tango ich werde berührt ergo sum
deswegen bin ich denn wenn wenn ich mehr
berührung vollkommen weg denke von mir
jegliche berührung wo bin ich dann das
weiß ich eben nicht mehr weil ich kein
gefühl kein gespür für mich mehr habe
das entsteht durch die berührung vor
allem durch andere menschen
die eine grenze überschreiten und dann
werde ich möglicherweise 1 mit diesem
anderen menschen in der liebe ist das
sehr häufig das gefühl aber die
missliche schmerzliche erfahrungen dabei
kann es nicht bleiben nicht innerhalb
des lebens sondern irgendwann entsteht
das bedürfnis wieder nach grenzziehung
so dass wir bei der berührung ständig
mit dem problem leben müssen
wann
wann spielt man ich wieder eine rolle ja
ich verstehe sie glaube ich gut das
haben sie auch in ihrem buch von der
kraft der berührung auch noch genauer
verdeutlicht warum sie gerade dafür
plädieren dass diese neue seitliche
ideen stammen von der kraft ich denke
also bin ich
nicht so trifft für das selbst sein und
doch würde ich gerne kritisch noch
einmal nachfragen
ob das wirklich so ist denn wir können
ja auch uns in der berührung täuschen
also wenn gekocht sozusagen nicht gerade
sich verleiten lässt diese formen der
selbsterfahrung als fundamental
anzusehen dann hat er es zumindest die
begründung zu sagen ich kann in jeder
form der zwischen mündlichen erfahrung
getäuscht werden ich kann meinen berührt
zu haben die wir auch im traum zum
beispiel viele berührungen erfahren aber
das war alles nur illusion
das einzige was beim ganzen sich
durchhält ist dass ich denke
er kann ja nicht denkt man nicht
körperlich der hals
also die voraussetzung des denkens ist
das körperliche sein und das körperliche
seien erfahre ich am intensivsten durch
berührung zum teil durch selbstbildung
aber in weit höherem maße durch
berührung durch andere und berührung von
anderen und dann existiere ich und wenn
ich körperlich existiere dann kann ich
noch das denken einschalten und kann
darüber reflektieren aber reflektieren
ohne körperliche sein kann ich mir
ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen
ja ich glaube diese wertschätzung von
berührung von körperlichkeit die wir
seit einigen jahrzehnten ein haben in
der wissenschaft in der gesellschaft
musste vielleicht erstmal durch diese
sinne skepsis hindurch also dass man
erkannt hat wie sehr wahrnehmung unsere
welt konstruktion mitprägt also
descartes hat ja auch schriften über die
optik über das auge descartes wusste
bereits dass auf der netzhaut die bilder
auf dem kopf stehen und das war
natürlich dann anlass zu fragen wie
zuverlässig sind eigentlich unsere sinne
oder wo kommt eigentlich die setzung von
welt her das was ich als wirklichkeit
erleben
und gerade weil das alles so relativ und
auf unser menschliches sinnes system
zurück zu beziehen ist
gerade deshalb kann ich inzwischen ein
weiteres konzept von kuki zu haben denn
inzwischen versteht man unter kognition
ja sowohl das emotionale als auch das
sinnliche das ist ja gar nicht zu
trennen in unserem zentralen
nervensystem in dem nervensystem dass
alle unsere organe unserer haut
enerviert das ist eine einheit also dass
wir das trennen von sinnes systemen vom
sechsten siebten sinn sprechen das ist
ja nachträglich in der sprache in der
verarbeitung ist es immer schon
intermodal sa und insbesondere auch wenn
diese religiös fassen sind religiöse
rituale die sich auch um berührungen
bemühen und kreisend wie zum beispiel
reinheit und reinheit rituale nehmen wir
einfach ritt im islam die berührung des
korans muslime für gewöhnlich berühre
nicht den koran ohne feuer sich geeinigt
zu haben und diese sie reinigen heißt es
nicht seine hinter mal gewaschen zu
haben denn das wäre dann die primitive
form von sauberkeit sondern es geht um
eine rituelle waschung das heißt es geht
um eine ganz andere tiefere form von
einstellung zum dem was dürfen baum
gottes für die muslime sein soll was
wiederum auch das als körper da ist der
koran ist ja da und diese daseinsform
ist wie sie es auch sagen wir auch
energetisch denn die rezitation des
korans geht muslimen unter die haut das
heißt das buch sie ist sie sind jetzt
vom göttlichen
da ist auch eine gewisse versöhnung auch
dann zu sehen sich in dem extremen form
von bbe kraft und vielleicht die andere
form zu sagen ohne denken kennen wir
auch aus
interessant ist ja was geschieht dann
nach der lektüre des koran oder was
geschieht nach einem gebet oder wären
dann im gebet
menschen fühlen sich bestärkt fühlen
sich kraftvoller haben mehr energie also
indem sie das transzendente berühren
soll heißen sich wieder mit dem
wesentlichen befassen gedanklich und in
gefühlen
schlitten öffnen sie die tore für diese
energie die im prinzip immer da ist es
liegt nur daran dass wir uns auch öffnen
dafür menschen die
diese öffnung aus irgendwelchen gründen
nicht zustande kriegen oder auch nicht
zustande kriegen wollen müssen mit den
bescheidenen energien leben die ihnen
dann übrig bleiben und das ist in der
regel zu wenig fürs leben und ich möchte
auf ein phänomen noch aufmerksam machen
dass menschen die sehr viel berührung
erfahren in berührung starken
beziehungen von kindheit an und später
eben in der liebe dass diese menschen
selten am sinn des lebens zweifeln
kann es sein dass die berührung den sinn
des lebens vermittelt und wenn ja wie
geht das wenn ja dann geht das indem
über die berührungen energie erfahren
wird und dann ein mensch kraftvoll und
zuversichtlich leben kann wären diese
energie zu entbehren die über berührung
im mich kommen kann heißt es macht mich
kraftlos und kraftlosigkeit mündet in
sinnlosigkeit netz nennt es diese
menschen zweifeln am sinn des lebens ja
das sieht was ich aber nicht verstehe
ist also kulturhistorisch gesehen oder
auch philosophisch religiös gesehen was
die reflexion über die berührung
anbetrifft spätestens seit aristoteles
scheint das sehen eine ganz eigene
karriere gemacht zu haben da sehen gilt
als der wichtigste sind so dass
zumindest ein europäisch westlich
abendländische kulturen wie man sie auf
dem fasten will worin liegt das
an ignoranz nicht
nur die sinne können täuschen herr
grammy auf das denken kann täuschen und
wie können wir dem entgehen nur durch
immer neue kritische frage und durch
unterhaltung mit anderen menschen um
deren aspekte anzuhören und mit
einzubeziehen niemals davon auszugehen
wir haben jetzt alles zu ende erkannt
sondern immer davon auszugehen es gibt
noch mehr zu erkennen als das was ich
momentan erkenne ja ich konzert ihre
auch wenn der gesamten
philosophiegeschichte eine abwesenheit
weitgehende abwesenheit der berührung
und das ist verblüffend denn es ist der
erste sind der entsteht im mutterleib
schon in der siebten
schwangerschaftswoche wird der tastsinn
als erster geprägt als erster
ausgebildet war sehr wahrscheinlich
gründe hat denn das ist was das
heranwachsende wesen am meisten braucht
im mutterleib also im fruchtwasser
erstmal
ertasten was hier geschieht und es ist
übrigens auch der letzte sind der geht
sie können einen sterbenden menschen bis
zuletzt über berührungen über den tasten
erreichen nicht unbedingt sprechen nicht
unbedingt über blicke aber über den
tastsinn
ja vielleicht haben wir es zu diesem
thema was sie gerade an gespräche mit
einem kurzem auch spielt
was auch immer wir den lieben langen tag
tun was wir dabei sicher immer tun ist
spüren
der mensch kann nicht nicht für
darum ein kleines loblied auf unseren
tastsinn
er hat es verdient und nötig ist
unterschätzt vernachlässigt gar
und ist doch der erste der im mutterleib
entsteht lange bevor der mensch hört und
sieht spürt er und er ist der letzte der
uns verlässt bis kurz vor dem tod fühlt
der mensch noch dass es ihn gibt wissen
tut er es nicht mehr
wo berührungs hunger herrscht wohnt die
berührungs industrie es ist ein
lukratives geschäft mit dem
kommerzialisierten anfassen der kult um
die berührung treibt mitunter auch recht
ungewöhnliche blüten menschen lassen
sich zu tausenden in die arme von
umarmung künstlern fallen
oder verteilen gratis umarmungen in der
öffentlichkeit die weltweit aktive free
hak bewegung agitiert gegen die
vereinzelung für mehr
zwischenmenschliche nähe auf dieser welt
und die kuschel audi gehen noch etwas
weiter bis zum höhepunkt jeder kuschel
party dem kuschel auf
er spielt hand aufs herz ist das nicht
eher so dass wir mehr unser handy am tag
berühren als die menschen die wir lieben
ja das ist so aber ich möchte dem doch
was abgewinnen weil ich beobachte an mir
selbst und an anderen wie sie mit ihrem
smartphone umgehen sie streichen darüber
und sie tasten ganz vorsichtig darauf
das ist eine wunderbare übung um wieder
zu lernen
das übertragen auf einen menschen per
gräben einem selbst auf dem sofa sitzt
wunderbare ihr habt also jetzt zärtliche
berührung gelernt
dass dazu brauchten wir das handy dass
seine eigentliche funktion alle denken
das ist sonst wie für kommunikation und
für internet surfen oder nein es ist
dafür da um zu lernen wie berührungen
geht und jetzt übertragen das mache den
partner an eurer seite der oder die wird
nämlich dankbar dafür sein und ihr
werdet eine entdeckung machen und dann
werdet ihr das ausbauen und dann könnt
ihr das handy ja ins leben einbauen aber
das leben besteht dann wieder aus mehr
als nur aus einer technik
das ist die positivste art es ist
vielmehr zu beschreiten müssen steigen
dürfen auf der anderen seite scheint es
ja auch dass diese ständige berühren
weil wir es vielleicht doch häufiger
unser handy als übungsfeld benutzen als
wir sollten schon so sehr
fortgeschritten zu sein
dass wir in gewisser weise auch den
bezug zum anderen in gewisser weise
verlieren auf der ebene der berührung
und wenn wir es auch gerade religiös
fassen wir können den koran und das bad
von höheren die thora wir können auch
eine predigt digital uns anschauen auch
wirklich heiler die digital uns zu
heilen versuchen ohne uns wirklich so
berühren dass ihn auch ganz neue formen
religiöser einstellungen die jenseits
der berührung ersten grades zumindest
fungieren
ja da kann man viele beobachtungen
an stellen wie sich das neue praktiken
herausgebildet haben neue see
hörgewohnheiten
eine folge ist dass sich ganz andere
netzwerke bilden also dass über einen
bestimmten musikstil zum beispiel der
dann in diesen digitalen medien genossen
wird weltweit anders szenen
zusammenfügen das bleibt natürlich
ambivalent weil forschungen zeigen in
bezug auf berührungen heilung dass das
nicht diese intensität entwickelt nicht
diese körperlichen reaktionen auslöst
gleichzeitig ist so ein handy das man
bei sich führt etwas das mir auch
orientierung gibt in der welt das mich
durch die stadt für das mich die zeit
wahrnehmen lässt in kontakt bleiben
lässt also sehr sehr ambivalente befund
der da auch sehr ambivalente folgen eben
für religionen hat ja
und ich meine es könnte auch sein dass
die berührung ein art stellvertreterin
für etwas größere star ist vielleicht
für eine tiefe sehnsucht in uns
die nach etwas größerem vielleicht 100
sie haben siemens stiftung genannt aber
auch trost angenommen sein
was man beitrag können religionen dafür
leisten mich interessiert vor allem ihre
sicht deshalb weil sie sich auch mit
nicht nur mit diesen großen sogenannten
weltreligionen beschäftigen sondern mit
anderen kleineren formen religiöser
prominenz genau mit vielen alternativ
formen mit säkularen
formen in denen man etwa in solchen
kontaktmöglichkeiten geht in berührung
heilung körper praktiken sport würden
manche das sehen aber oft wird das ja
zum einstieg dann dass man auch in
meditation körperreinigung ein solches
dinge weiter vordringen ich glaube dass
der sinne schließt sich welchen
stellenwert berührung in diesen neuen
praktiken hat wenn wir uns vor augen
führen dass die zweite moderne sehr
stark reflexiv ist also wir als subjekte
in diesem postindustriellen
gesellschaften wir müssen über alles
mögliche rechenschaft ablegen wer wir
sind wie wir für uns sorgen welche
prävention werden bezug auf unsere
gesundheit treffen
und da ist jetzt dieses berührt werden
in einem guten berührungs biografie zu
stehen noch eine weitere aufgabe
geworden als es gehört zur selbstsorge
und das hat chancen und es hat
gleichzeitig eine bürde dass ich das
jetzt auch noch mich darum kümmern muss
werde ich genug berührt bin ich
psychisch gesund und intakt weil ich
entsprechende berührungen habe bin ich
authentisch weil ich andere in einer
ähnlichen weise berühren weil ich
sichtbar machen welche gefühle ich habe
und die sich dann so auch ausdrücken das
überfordert viele oder manche wollen das
auch gerne optimieren wie sie sich
zeigen und deswegen entsteht diese
nachfrage nach workshops nach
wochenenden nach ausbildungen etwa in
körpertherapie usw um diese starke
energie des berührend um mit der gut
umzugehen aber das ist der preis der
modernisierung
modernisierung heißt befreiung befreiung
von norman von vorgegebenen normen nicht
zuletzt der religion der tradition der
konvention wir wollen nicht mehr so
leben wir alle wir wollen nicht mehr so
leben wie opa wir wollen nicht mehr so
leben wie gott uns dass befiehlt also
die befreiung
ist als große gewinner verantworten von
sehr vielen menschen
insbesondere von seiten von frauen die
in hohem maße
enormen gehalten wurden über sehr lange
zeit und wir haben noch nicht so recht
verstanden was der preis dieser
befreiung ist nämlich die bevor die
freiheit nun auch bewältigen zu müssen
wissen sie menschen in vormodernen
zeiten hatten kein problem mit berührung
die lagen zu fünft und zu zehnt nachts
im bett eng aneinander geschmiegt weil
mehr wohnraum war nicht mehr bett war
dann nicht befreiung heißt jeder kriegt
ein eigenes zimmer und wir können uns
das auch leisten dass jeder ein eigenes
zimmer hat und jetzt sind wir separiert
und jetzt entdecken wir die berührung
und jetzt ist es eine schlimme arbeit
die wir auch noch machen müssen nein ich
würde sagen es ist eine freudige arbeit
es ist die arbeit der freiheit die wir
auf diese weise vollziehen indem wir uns
eben nicht nur befreien sondern dieser
freiheit nun auch eigene formen geben
eigene vorne das zuletzt die formen die
wir selbst ausfindig machen können es
ist nicht mehr gesetzt dass ein mann
seine frau schlagen kann nach belieben
wie das in form moderner zeiten üblich
war sondern jetzt müssen wir uns eben
verständigen welche bildung zu welcher
zeit ja das ist erstmal sehr sehr
anstrengend ich sehe das auch so aber
letzten endes werden wir in den formen
der freiheit leben können die wir mal
so ich glaube nicht dass es jemals ein
unschuldiges berühren oder natürliches
berühren gab sondern das zeigen ja viele
tabuisierung 'nen ganz klare auch
anleitungen für sexualität für reinheit
in verschiedenen kulturen religionen
dass es immer schon reguliert worden
weil es eben diese kraft und diese
gefährlichkeit hat mit der emotionalität
dinge durcheinander zu bringen oder auch
dieses verletzungs potenzial hat was
sich verändert hat dass ausdrücklicher
darüber befunden wird und vielleicht
auch weniger kollektiv eine form
gefunden wird sondern einzelne er für
sich entscheiden müssen auch je nachdem
was für einem kleineren kontext autobahn
oder ländlich in was für einer
familienform in was für einem sexuellen
orientierung auch da wären viel
breiteres spektrum inzwischen sie leben
als es ist der preis der moderne ist es
eine bürde ist es zugleich natürlich
auch eine show augusta die
individualität stärker zu verwirklichen
aber ich glaube diese kollektiv formen
die man sich ja auch nach corona
eventuell wieder wünscht dass wir wieder
einen größeren konsens haben eine
größere selbstverständlichkeit wie
begrüßt man wie sind zu gewissen
situationen zwischenmenschliche
organisiert die ist nicht mehr so stark
wie natürlich in der vor individuellen
gesellschaft liegt es vielleicht auch an
diesem was sie nennen nicht neutralität
der berührung dass die berührung auch
eine ganz andere seite hat nämlich einer
nötigen der gewaltsame
beängstigende die wiederum dann auch
religiös eine
besondere rolle leider heute mehr denn
je spielt aber bleiben wir erstmal bei
dem profanen wenn sie an miet debatten
denken wenn sie auch an ganz anderen
gesellschaftlichen
missstände denken da ist die berührung
ganz vorne mit dabei na ja woran liegt
es oder gibt es wie würden sie diese
andere seite der berührung beschreiben
in der vorbereitung dieser sendung hat
mich eine kluge praktikantin darauf
aufmerksam gemacht und das wort hier
genau hier passend die super nicht viel
mehr von anfassen fonds aktion von das
auch ansprechen soll und nicht von
berührung das ist immer das falsche wort
ja das gehört zu unserer momentan
hysterie es ist immer das falsche wort
also bleiben wir ruhig bei berührung das
ist ein wort das was weckt anfassen
weckt nicht viel berührung ist es heimat
ist es beispielsweise auch nicht so sehr
zu hause also es gibt worte in denen
einfach mehr mit schwingt als in anderen
und dem entkommen wir nicht dadurch dass
wir das wort einfach zur seite
wir bleiben bei berührung und dann ist
es einfach scheint mir grundsätzlich so
es gibt keine rein positiven phänomene
es gibt auch keine rein negativen
phänomene soll heißen auch in sowas
positiven berührung steckt auch etwas
negatives und das ist nun mal dass sie
eine form annehmen kann die den
betroffenen nicht willkommen ist so
können wir das unterscheiden willkommene
erwünschte berührung und nicht
erwünschten nicht willkommene berührung
und das phänomen ist wir können das an
uns selber testen wir sind berührende
und berührte menschen was tut mir gut an
berührung und was nicht von wem tut sie
mir gut und von wem nicht und genau ist
so ist es umgekehrt auch meine bildung
tut anderen gut oder auch nicht und dem
gut und jenem nicht und wenn ich mich
beobachte wie das bei mir ist gewinne
ich mehr sensibilität dafür wie das bei
anderen sein könnte und dann kann ich
vielleicht auch mal gezielt danach vor
ist das okay wenn ich dich wenn ich dich
begrüße dass ich dir ein kuss links eins
rechts auf die wange drückte oder ist
dir das zu viel oder möchtest du noch
einen dritten wie das in der schweiz
früher üblich war oder möchtest du
lieber keinen kuss
und dann haben wir noch gar nicht
gesprochen über die gewaltsam eine
berührung die in früheren zeiten
üblich war auch als ich als kind groß
wurde war es noch üblich
dass wir geschlagen wurden in der schule
und teilweise auch zu hause und das
fanden wir normal weil der kulturelle
kontext war so wären wir heute nicht im
traum auf den gelang hoffentlich nicht
auf den gedanken kommen würden dass
unsererseits zu praktizieren insofern
kann sich also die führungskultur in
einer kultur vehement verändern er
verstehe und genau diese in leider
werden kinder heute immer noch
verprügelt
hier und woanders
und frauen berührt wenn sich ja auch
nicht berührt werden wollen kann es gibt
genügend auch zeugnisse dafür dass die
berührung uns in irgendeiner weise auch
nicht gut tut und schon gar nicht wenn
sie religiös geformt ist
so dass ich fast schon geneigt bin sie
zu fragen ob
wir nicht in einer berührungs krise der
religionen gerade
sind oder uns dahin bewegen
also die eine berührungs krise hängt mit
dem ead debatte auch zusammen dass ich
da eine normalität verschoben hat und
dinge nicht mehr als normal akzeptiert
werden und auch nicht mehr verschwiegen
werden die verletzten sind die opfer
produzieren die missbräuchlich berührt
worden sind das war eine machtausübung
das war eine fehlende ist fehlende
kontrolle die hier dazu führt und nicht
nur im christentum also wir haben das
auch bei verschiedenen
modernen westlichen buddhismus formen wo
noch mal da erschwerend auch hinzu kommt
dass wir da charismatische gestalt denn
oft haben in einer gewissen tradition
die stück weit auch mit verehrt werden
und da dann noch mal bestimmte
abhängigkeitsverhältnisse zwischen
diesen personen hier
abhängigkeitsverhältnisse mit hinein
kommen das wird aufgearbeitet jetzt in
ganz vielen gruppierungen das hat lange
gedauert auch in der yoga szene die er
sehr körperlich ist wo man noch mal ganz
neu auch gucken muss was darf da berührt
werden wie muss ich mir ein
einverständnis
einholen was ist in einem indischen
kontext vielleicht anders als oft wurde
sowas dann auch entschuldigend
herangezogen für bestimmte berührungs
formen da ist jetzt wirklich ein anderes
bewusstsein da und zwar sowohl von denen
die potenziell betroffen sind als auch
die die sowas vielleicht zu
unreflektiert ausgeübt haben also zum
glück hat sich dann enorm auch
verschoben ja und um die frage bleibt
die man noch weiter so aktuell ist wie
wenn sie an den übergriffen in der
katholischen kirche die kinder
anbetrifft denken aber auch andere
formen der über eingriffe die auch sehr
zentral die berührung brauche
mitträgt
was kann man dagegen tun schmidt sie
haben eine kommunikative
regulierung vorgeschlagen dass man
vorher sich verständigt was ist für dich
okay das ist für mich okay aber es gibt
auch religionen die verfestigte rituale
haben eine eigene sozialisation haben es
gibt nunmal dieser verschieben was
können wir da tun denn so kann es ja
eigentlich insgesamt nicht weitergehen
ja das ist eine sehr komplexe frage
letztlich sind das die
zivilgesellschaften die das regeln
müssen die sich da einsetzen müssen dass
bestimmte hierarchische oder
struktur nicht mehr möglich sind dass
eine höhere transparenz da sein muss
dass bestimmte personenkreise nicht aus
der strafverfolgung ausgenommen werden
dürfen also zum beispiel missbrauchs
berichte in bezug auf sportvereine in
bezug auf kirchen haben da ein ganzes
bündel an faktoren wie man auch
pädagogisch junge menschen darauf
vorbereiten kann wie man auf klärt
darüber wie man da eine höhe transparenz
schafft also da gibt es ja sehr sehr
viele vorschläge wie man damit umgeht
aber es muss eine zivile gesellschaft da
sein die sich um so was kümmert wenn es
abgeschlossene gruppierungen gibt auch
in deutschland ja bestimmte religiöse
kleinere gruppierungen die weiter
strafen körperlich strafen zum beispiel
muss man schauen wie man da eine
kommunikation geht oder welche
rechtlichen möglichkeiten man hat
ja den tatort und gerade gerade religiös
um es eine noch eine tiefere ebene da
hinein zu bauen ist durchaus reizvoll
interessant und fraglich sogleich warum
gott also die frucht um die sich alles
dreht
und vorüber ist denken sie an
michelangelo und sein erschaffung des
menschen in der sixtinischen kapelle wo
wir zwei energien sehen wie sie sagen
würden zu recht die zugeneigt sind sich
in irgendeiner weise energetisch auch
berühren aber doch es gibt eine distanz
zwischen eben aber man sieht den funken
förmlich überspringen ja er bei dieser
berührung zwischen adam und gott bei der
wir nicht sicher sein können wer da wen
zum leben erweckt
das kann sehr wohl sein dass ist der
mensch ist der gott zum leben erweckt
soll heißen über ihn spricht ihn
anbietet ihn verehrt was er vorher
möglicherweise gar niemand gemacht hat
also insofern liegt schon auch was
andere menschen und da springt der funke
über mag sein dass es keinen kontakt
gibt aber wir kennen das aus der erotik
dass das natürlich die die
energetisch den situationen sind in
denen wir noch eine gewisse distanz
bewahren ich verstehe gerade gerade
erotik ist also mir immer noch bei
unserem thema ist ja auch zweischneidig
auf der einen seite einer der schönsten
erfahrungen auf der anderen seite die
auf dem missbrauchter form der berührung
weil wir in irgendeiner weise vielleicht
auch religiös sozialisiert das
unberührbare begehren warum
weil die sehnsucht nach berührung
überwältigend ist ein bisschen wie einer
der berührendsten stellen in den
evangelien für mich ist als der
auferstandene jesus sichtbar wird für
maria magdalena und sehr verständlich
sie auf ihn zugeht und ja dann sagen
wird berühre mich nicht
wieso sagte dass
ich glaube schon dass selbst auch in der
christlichen tradition des mit dem
berühren so eine ambivalenz hat
einerseits ist es ja sehr berührt auch
dieser gott ist mensch geworden
und fordert den thomas auf ihn zu
berühren wenn es braucht und
gleichzeitig gibt es diese hochschätzung
das nicht berühren diese ganzen
vermeidungs formen um diese besonderheit
dieser gottheit auch zu kennzeichnen
also man sich religionen breite anschaut
gibt es jetzt wohl das optimum das
götter bäume berge wesenheiten ganz
selbstverständlich berührt werden sei es
mit den knien mit den lippen mit den
händen einverleibt werden über nahrung
die man teilt er gut ernährt werden und
andererseits auf traditionen in denen
das gerade nicht genommen wird es sind
formen die zu unterschiedlichen
gestaltungen des berührend diskus
torischen führen wie man besonderheit
die hohe bedeutung die hohe soziale
emotionale bedeutung dieser instanz
dieser religiösen instanz ausdrückt dir
dann wieder eine gesellschaft oft mit
auch und dadurch extrem wichtig ist für
das für die stabilisierung einer
bestimmten gesellschaft und es ist ein
machtspiel nicht zu vergessen leider es
ist ein machtspiel noli metalle rühr
mich nicht an das kann eben auch eine
machtausübung seien auch in der
beziehung zwischen zweien rühr mich
nicht an berühre mich nicht ich gestatte
dir nicht diese vertrautheit ich habe
nicht das vertrauen ich möchte dich auf
distanz halten und möglicherweise
ausgesprochen oder unausgesprochen bist
du so bist wie ich das will bis ich
wieder in dem zustand bin der mir passt
es ist ein schwieriges spiel der
berührung schon zwischen zwei und wenn
sie sich auch in unserer gegenwart
hinein gehen das gebot der globalen
pandemie lautetet er
brüllte ich nicht da kommt sozusagen
etwas als gebot was was sie in der
ganzen sendung versuchen hoch zu
schätzen wie bedeutungsvoll eigentlich
berührung ist und dann ist gerade die
berührung die als eine art
zwischenmenschliche gefahr
sich auftut und
zugleich wir durch die berührung oder
prüfungs losigkeit wie elisabeth an sagt
jedoch in einer berührungslose
gesellschaft uns doch immer mehr
einfinden wo wir doch sehr viel
sehnsucht nach berührung haben aber doch
weil wir wissen dass berührung auch
verletzlichkeit bedeutet wo sie genau
das uns nicht antun wollen und wir
stehen zwischen zwei polen und das wird
sicherlich noch sehr viel stärker werden
einerseits der überwältigenden sehnsucht
nach berührung aus gutem grund weil das
gibt uns energie und das gibt uns denn
das ist elementar und existenziell
andererseits aber die moderne behauptung
meine freiheit meine autonomie ich
bestimme
was heißt ich bestimme wenn der andere
aber darüber bestimmen kann ob er oder
sie mehr berührung gibt oder nicht da
gerät meine autonomie an grenzen und der
stärke ich meine autonomie betonen desto
weniger berührung werde ich haben je
mehr berührung ich habe desto weniger
fertig meine autonomie behaupten kann
das ist das ist die spannung in der wir
in moderner welt leben und das sehe ich
auch da gehen wir noch durch schwierige
zeiten durch das heißt sie würden schon
sagen dass wir eine neue führungskultur
benötigen wenn kinder in kindergärten
die sich verletzt haben nicht trost
empfinden finden weil die erzieherin
sich kaum mehr trauen diese kinder
möglich den arm zu nehmen oder wenn
ältere menschen auch während der
pandemie nicht berührt worden sind
in dieser berührungs armut auch eine
tiefe einsamkeit verspürt haben nicht
wenige sind auch das hat vielleicht
verstorben die pandemie ist das kleinste
problem das ist ein vorübergehendes
phänomen das den großen vorteil hatte
mit allen schlimmen erfahrungen für
einzelne menschen den großen vorteil es
hat uns bewusst gemacht wie wichtig
berührung ist indem wir sie nicht haben
konnten das war nötig die lektion haben
wir verstanden das größte problem ist
die moderne welt die eine großartige
errungenschaft ist aber die
problematische situation mit sich bringt
eben die spannung zwischen der einzelnen
autonomie die in einer vehemenz
behauptet wird wie noch niemals zuvor in
der menschheitsgeschichte und
andererseits aber dem bedürfnis nach
berührung nach zusammensein mit anderen
menschen je mehr wir autonomie haben
behaupten desto weniger werden wir dazu
fähig sein also wie können wir das
regulieren dass wir eine autonomie
gewinnen die porträts ist so können wir
vielleicht sagen eine poröse
weiche autonomie eine nachgiebige
autonomie und auf die weise mehr
berührung zustande bekommen da müssen
wir sicherlich in wir müssen zu einer
berührung skulptur warum müssen wir
woanders nicht existieren können vielen
dank dieses schöne schlusswort und danke
ihnen für das erhellende gespräch
nächsten sonntag sehen sie hier in der
sternstunde religion ein gespräch bei
dem es um ein berührung stubbs geht dann
heißt es nämlich achtung
menstruationsblut hier geht es nun
weiter mit der sternstunde philosophie
und der österreichischen kabarettisten
und schriftstellerin elisa eckert die
besonders gerne tabus bricht ihnen einen
bildungs runden sonntag
[Musik]